yeah okay
we carry feet sipping empathy I don't
patience is the key put enough [ __ ] for
free this is tea we carry v Michael
makeup good morning it is tea with
garyvee on this April 30th in 2020 20
tomorrow is the first day of May and so
this is the last day of April and so
let's get right into the show Gary how
are you doing I'm well Spencer how are
you wow it feels great to be here man it
feels great to finally get to help you
although it's not face to face we are
social distancing meeting right now I
wish I was in New York yeah I haven't
talked with you man it feels great to be
here I'm gonna get into it give a little
bit of context to everyone that's
listening right now I am a beatboxer so
I make music out of my face and yeah I'm
living my dreams in Hollywood right now
I have followed your advice for the past
four years so this is really really
crazy that we're hearing this better and
that's another success thank you so much
dude thank you so much for spending you
that D on the other day and saying
congrats on everything that's happening
with me it really really means a lot to
me especially coming from you um I was
homeless last year my guy I was homeless
last year and I was figuring a way to
piece things together I was looking
myself in the mirror and I'm like hey
look if you really really want this you
want to be the guy for this you got to
put in the work and I watched you
religiously I did I watch it religiously
and I was fighting adversity and I got
early on - tik-tok really really early
on we talked and I'd support the game I
put a beat out every single day and I
saw those are my mixtapes
and I put it out every single day and
I'm like in 365 days if this doesn't
work then maybe something else is
happening
but right now I'm spinning at the top 10
within the platform which is insane
because I went from not really having a
home and being in a
windowless room to having an audience
having attention having people around me
that really really care about me I'm
getting ad deals I'm talking to agencies
right now I'm looking to release a song
within the next a little bit more than a
month but we're planning it out right
now
I'm very really exciting so my question
is for people that are in my position
you talk a lot about getting to the
certain place you know finding your
group of people or finding your audience
and right now people are gravitating
towards me mostly to build a bigger
vision something more sustainable which
I really want to do I want to bring back
to everyone that's given to me so um
yeah in hopes of forming a team I
noticed that's what you have built so
strongly who are people in a modern and
perhaps future business who are some key
players who are people that you can't
live without I you know I think a couple
things one in the same way that you kind
of took a step back and said let me be
patient but thoughtful and and you took
advantage of the new attention on a
platform and it's put you on this path I
think the first person you start with is
a right-hand person just an admin you
know assistant like just a like a
confidant somebody you can trust you
know then that would be my starting
point and and and then really you start
building around you the people I can't
live without might be different than who
you can't live without meaning you know
for example you know I I despise
logistics I I need an admin to make sure
I know where I'm going or things of that
nature so I think you gonna need to
figure out what you need some people
need a PR person around them to get
attention
I did not some people need a sales
person around them I do not you know so
you really need to think about who you
need around you for you less about me
it's about you being self-aware but I
think giving your circumstance
especially going from homeless to this
the extremes of one year what I want to
do is make sure you really you know
gather your thoughts over the last four
years do the stuff you've heard for me
which is look for a kind
good person that can really bring you
value and and and complements the things
that you don't want to be doing i
hundred percent agree with what you're
saying like you say double down on your
strengths and for the weaknesses you
know build on them but know that other
people can do better and have them help
you so right now that's a really really
big thing i have a very small you need
to you need to slow it down even more
than you think right now even though it
seems like the time to use a slow it
down in your mind and press hard in your
actions so you need to be making more
content right now you need to do how you
know when i DM do you I'm trying to
remember now how big is your audience on
Instagram Instagram is not nearly as big
as tickety I don't know so much
it's at like 750 K a little bit above
that right now I would probably if I
what if I were you yeah I know if I were
you I would probably make a single piece
of tick-tock content a day that was
moving the audience to YouTube and
Instagram and Twitter I would do that I
mean day once a gap okay today today's
like today's like a Twitter reply day
everyone like boom boom you do your
beatboxing you're like yo first 500
people that reply on Twitter I'm gonna
reply you to mmm you're back
I like that well I get pumped because
your audience loves you you got 40
million in that Youth world but now
you're building I want you to diversify
out of tick tock I so I watch their
actions to be more hardcore but in your
brain I don't want you buying things I
don't want you over hiring things you
know I don't want you you know I don't
want you to think like your agent who
your managers gonna be is gonna like
completely put you know like you need to
be smart I've listened to you so far I
haven't I haven't monetized my audience
at all you're thinking about coming out
with merch on the next month which could
work which could work there's a million
ways to do it but like punchline being
slowed it down
yes be more thoughtful be more focused
stay hungry be grateful talk to you soon
my god thank you
take care great kids doing a really good
job
crushing tick-tock hi Gary how are ya
I'm well Chris how are you good I'll
just get right into it so a little bit
of background context at 15 I bought my
I'm a Chicago land DJ at 15 I bought my
own mixer I took all the money in my
bank account I spend it on one mixer for
six months straight I locked myself in a
room and six hours a day I just taught
myself how to mix and I did that for six
months before I went on a Carnival
Cruise and I met the armoire DJ and he
actually saw you know what I taught
myself then he actually him and I
exchanged contact info he is not my
mentor and I have a internship set up
you know in the future after I graduate
high school and so after I came back I
joined a family business um for DJing
and I have an Instagram and every single
week I forced myself to release a new
mix every Monday and I released two
other posts um during the week so I'm
active on it activist yeah I don't
really three posts a week I think is
quite low okay I just don't like I want
to I only have you know 65 followers on
there and I I guess I guess I just don't
want to like flood how many posts are
coming out you're definitely not
flooding them so I just wanted to know
you know what more can I do how do I
expand my growth how do I like by
posting more yeah I like how am I gonna
I don't know how am I gonna like get
more followers how how am I gonna like I
guess get a following and get to where I
want to be people get very confused and
get tactical instead of looking at
things in the macro how does how did
Martin Luther King get more influence
and get a movement by him he spoke
in more churches okay so how many Nicole
Jackson and Prince and Madonna become
the you know the dominating music forces
of the 80s their [ __ ] videos played
24/7 on MTV brother I'd rather you have
the 60 you're playing defense you're
like oh I'm gonna flood the 65 it's
gonna go to 42 without realizing it
people's three times a day that 65 is
gonna go to 650 okay anybody everybody
worries about what's gonna go wrong
instead of focusing on what's gonna go
right you're in a defensive mindset so
okay um I haven't gone to take talk for
DJ real quick I apologize cuz Claude
diamond in the comments brings up the
question that people struggle with when
I say this is the quality or quantity
quality is subjective whether I like
your [ __ ] beats or not is my
subjective call there's people that
think you know some of the greatest
artists of all time are overrated or
underrated you know what I mean that's
qaulity is subjective mmm quantity is
not its [ __ ] mad okay
so essentially the more that I put out
the higher chance of people seeing it
just think about that sentence and just
break it down with me like like you know
it's funny because I get it I actually
have a lot of empathy where your mindset
is which where most people are of course
by nature of what you just said like
three posts a day on Instagram three
posts a day on tick-tock 1215 posts on
Twitter you know one YouTube video a day
yes by but that's exactly right I can't
control your quality I don't I can't
control if you're Timbaland or if you're
or if you're not I can't control that
but I could tell you right now the more
somebody posts the more their phone
forced to create and id8 the board
expands their ability to be creative and
it gives them more opportunities to get
you know awareness and opportunity 99%
of people that are out there and 98% of
people that follow me
go the other way you know hide behind
perfection or other you know facades to
not put out more because of insecurities
or laziness or lack of drive or lack of
conviction or many other variables thus
giving them almost no chance of success
so what if I were to migrate to tik-tok
which honestly it's not here not
migrating it's adding okay so you know I
want you to [ __ ] everywhere
just cuz Martin Luther King gave a talk
in a small Church in Memphis didn't mean
that he couldn't go then give a big talk
in a you know in a big hall in DC mm-hmm
the answer is always more and you're
trying to amass a tension to give you
opportunity to do something you love so
neat by even common sense that needs
more reps so you know I was thinking you
know what do I post on Tic Tac Toe just
follow trends because it's it's a weird
gray area that I'm in ready for this
both make one trend make a talking video
you know make another you know that a
third trend comes you know wait a minute
I can creatively mix that into what I do
well mm-hmm the answer is yes okay
like literally this is like a zen-like
my concept of communication is almost
zen-like it's like yes more yes yes
everyone's asking these questions and
I'm like the [ __ ] are we asking these
questions for do you want to follow a
trend yes
do you want to dance sure I've been made
a dancing video because I can't forget
you the pop lock like you know but like
if you can't do it oh you know I mean a
wine video you know I wanted to make a
wine you know I haven't made a wine
video on musically slash tik-tok for
four years but I finally feel it's old
enough and I feel comfortable enough
that I made one of those like a couple
of posts ago like yes there's also going
to Twitter you have a Twitter account or
now yes and searching terms in your
industry
like literally Twitter search you know
and you search you know
not generic but esoteric terms in your
business you know in mixing culture you
type them in you see people talking jump
in and reply and go into those
conversations okay but do you think the
I'm doing the right thing you know I'm
also what not only with this family
business but I'm also going to other
like I'm looking up like other party
groups I guess in Chicago and I'm going
to them I'm saying you know if you need
a DJ Here I am I have yes its Leal's
that's sales you do no job with sales
you're not doing a good job with brand
yeah I guess yeah that's that's why I
think I came on here today just because
I literally just need to find a way how
to grow that fan base I guess how to
grow that number it's tough to grow
anything if you're not watering it and
content is water mm-hmm so okay alright
on you know on Twitter then I'll make
you know text post saying like hey you
know here's what's coming out how are
you guys doing this is you know I would
talk I would talk more about the overall
genre
nobody cares yet about what you've got
coming out just like Mogan out here that
I was nobody cared like my opinion on
wine at first for the first two years I
just talked about wine mm-hmm got it
no all right so I would more or less
talk less about you your sales your your
I like where you're at on sales but when
you make content you have to bring them
value not make it about what you you
need to make about it or that so on
Twitter then I would just be like you
know if the Billboard Top 10 you know
look at them and be like hey look at
this music you know this is what's
happening in the community yes then I go
on to tick tock you know I do at Charlie
D'Amelio after all I care that's right
that's right I mean you do you know in
three a day so if you're gonna do at
Charlie or if you're gonna just sit
there and talk or if you're gonna follow
a trend and make one of those yes okay
so all right thank you right you got a
brother talk to you soon you too yeah
all right
looking a little younger this morning
caught Dustin off-guard Dustin you
didn't see you know I had a little fun
last night
before I fully shaved it off I did
something pretty good I was gonna I was
gonna come in great eyes for everyone
watching just to see Jeremy how are you
hey how's it going Gary good dude this
is awesome it truly an honor and
privilege just to get on this is really
cool yeah so my question revolves around
ad spend on social media okay I recently
published a book back in January is when
it went live or for sale on like Amazon
and everybody and this was a book was
kind of a story about my experiences as
a kid being bullied and what I went
through and then kind of evolved into
discussing a little bit about how it
affected me later on in life and then
what my thoughts are on how to fix the
epidemic which is just growing and
growing every year the I'm in probably
2/3 of the way done with my second book
which is you know gonna cover some
topics about all of the failures in my
life everything from you know when I
started out I was gonna write about all
the failures of managers and bosses that
I ever worked for and kind of point the
finger saying here's how this guy
screwed up and you know I was gonna say
why that was wrong and here's how they
should have acted and then I I realize
that that was ridiculous of me to try to
write something like that and I actually
after watching a lot of your content I I
really changed my whole perspective on
that and said alright here's
everywhere.i Jeremy on that point where
yeah were you able to see the
attractiveness of accountability yes
actually you know what it was
I want to say probably in the second
book was the first one I started writing
but as I started to write that book I'm
like wait a minute
I'm about to explain how all these
things failed why have I failed at so
many different things and that's when I
kind of did a lot of soul-searching and
went and wrote my first book about my
bullying experiences but it was I want
to say January of last year in 2019 I
was because at the gym running on a
treadmill or something and I was out for
a run I don't know but I was listening
to one of your keynotes in my headphones
as I'm running and I want to say it was
probably a keynote you did in Singapore
Philippines somewhere I think it was
overseas I believe and I don't know what
the show was the conference was but in
the middle of it you're addressing all
these entrepreneurs and you were making
the point about accountability you said
look everything that happens at
vaynermedia is my fault
100% and I can't remember I just
literally stopped there I was doing and
I was like holy [ __ ] and I really
started listening right now it's like
wow and it just completely opened up
everything for me and you know what you
know what's crazy about it I actually
genuinely mean it I generally like you
know I really I really believe that you
know like it's you know my you know it's
it's and it's and it's empowering
you know people people love the
short-term good feeling of blaming
someone else but it leads to very very
very bad long-term life on the flip side
you know it's not fun to say this is
[ __ ] up because of me but that's like
a short-term pain and long-term it's
created incredible serenity and peace
and happiness for me I feel fully in
control oh absolutely
well let's say you know you always used
to say that you know a lot of your
haters say who cares about Gary he just
says the same thing every time well I
don't think that's the point to make the
point real point is you're consistent in
your message and that's what I loved
about it and you know the I took that to
heart and so the one I'm writing now is
basically you know I'm looking at things
that I failed or drop the ball on and
instead of point the thing
a boss who may have dropped the ball or
treated me terribly I can at least start
to identify here's what I should've did
and here's how a rag could act in that
situation including including some up
you know you can't control people and
you know if you have a terrible boss
like maybe you just need to work
somewhere else and that's you taking
control of it yeah no I love your hoodie
and I love this I love this country I
was born in the former Soviet Union but
like sometimes when people really get
upset with America I have a lot of
empathy because their experience may be
difficult but I always remind them like
you could move to Sweden you could sure
you know it seems extreme it's like
selling your home you know I know you
sound like you follow me like I took a
lot about selling your home when you
can't afford your lifestyle it seems
like when I started talking about it a
year and a half ago like the entire real
estate got upset with me this and that I
was like it's fine people can be upset
with me but like you could yeah you know
like to me I don't care about how money
compounds or what the value of something
is if one's unhappy there is no smarts
behind it I don't care that you make a
million dollars a year in this business
if it burns you to the ground in your
emotions it was a bad idea you were
better off you know doing this other
thing for 73 thousand a year I mean it's
not super complicated yes sir wasn't a
Australian big Australian radio show and
they were talking about like I was
talking about my optimism and the DJ was
like man you're a little too optimistic
he's like what about all the death I'm
like what about all the people that's
lives have been saved by kovat I mean
just does the world realize that if
COBIT started two months earlier Kobe
Bryant would be alive yeah like like you
know like like you know many people died
in traffic accidents every day in
America do you know how low that number
is right now because nobody's driving
crime rates down and everything yeah
like you know like people are you know
like yes there's incredible pain and
there's people have passed specifically
because of koban and they would have
lived for another 50 years and on the
flip side there's people that were going
to die because like and and and that's
where I get to in my mind which is like
it's just how you see it and you were
seeing it it's like it was Rick's fault
and Stan's fault and Jays fault and then
boom one [ __ ] sentence and you're
like
wait a minute and and that
accountability leads to control because
when you think it's everybody else's
fault
you feel so sad cuz you're like [ __ ]
they're in control
people are state control is the
happiness control I hated my last
corporate boss that I had before I left
my job I hated him you because he was a
true bully and and I didn't I didn't
know how to deal with him and what made
it worse was the fact that I looked at
this guy is he's affecting my you know
not only just me but my family's
financial well-being he's affecting
whether or not you know everything I and
I so my hate for this guy grew more and
more and it's like I look back on it now
I'm like I could have handled this guy
so much better I lost a lot of my focus
because I was just so focused on the
fact that he didn't like me and he
didn't you know it seemed like he wanted
to push me out the door and you know I
mean a lot of guys on our team felt that
way but and I think I think what people
don't understand is getting pushed out
the door aka walking out the door is a
powerful move yeah you know most people
feel like that guy won I don't because
when everybody walks out the door that
guy gets fired by what's above him yeah
people are confused every single person
here is actually 100% in charge this is
a huge moment I really appreciate you
coming on you're getting me going here
like this is like like really going down
a path I want to you're actually 100% in
charge you actually are what is required
to get out of the most difficult
situations may feel super uncomfortable
or not the ideology of how you saw it
but once you change your ideology and
once you stop putting something on a
pedestal a dream a thought an idea and
instead just living in the actual moment
you actually realize you're 100% in
charge you can move you can you can you
can get divorced you can quit a job you
can you can do anything if you've got
humility and confidence if you really
need confidence you can do everything
mm-hmm I believe that 100% yes I think
that's kind of the joy of being a small
business owner too that you know we've
whatever
whether it's a pizza shop or a you know
a media company or whatever it is you
have that you're the business owner it's
all on you you know you know you know
many people bought homes cars and went
on vacations in the last two years that
they couldn't afford on the paper and a
small business owners that are now
blaming Co vid like Oh see the world
hates me I'm like oh the world doesn't
hate you
knew had a bad behavior the last several
years you could have been saving money
and you could be using that money right
now growing your business but you took
the money out of the business and you
bought a Porsche a hundred percent I
know what I owe you know it's like the
people right now I've put out a couple
comments on Facebook and Twitter here
and there about you know all right we're
all on quarantine for the last almost
two months now what are we all doing you
know I know most people are sleeping in
most people are just hanging out and and
it's good to relax a little bit but I
also said what better time to do
something try something you know it's
not I'm not saying everybody just needs
to get out and start running ten miles
it's you know is there a hobby you
wanted to get into is or books you
wanted to read things you've that have
been stacking up in your life that you
haven't been able to do hello this is
the time if there's so much one could
get somebody hit me up the other day
they carry feel useless I'm not do
anything I want to get back I have no
money I'm like you could have retweeted
the all in challenge Dustin
like like you're following me every day
watching eight hours a day I'm talking
about this thing
I'm not even asking you for the $10.00
raffle ticket to go into my thing you
could just share it on your Facebook in
Italy it ninety-nine percent of the
people watching this every [ __ ]
morning have not even shared all in
challenge calm right like because people
don't get that they're in control people
talk [ __ ] Jeremy but I want to give back
but I don't have the resources sure you
do you have 14 followers on Twitter
that's called resources you have 11 you
have a hundred thirteen you know context
in your cell phone you can literally say
have you checked out this all and
challenge by a ten dollar raffle ticket
every [ __ ] person here could do that
and feed somebody that's hungry for all
the [ __ ] hundreds of emails I'm
getting every day of I wish I could I
wish I could be giving back right now
you can it's not just money it's
awareness
it's a million thing you know like I
don't get it you could go down that list
of the all of the challenges and just
find one and say that this challenge my
friend or cousin there's one there's one
there's one every single person here if
you can go to the Instagram profile on
the Twitter of your favorite celebrity
an athlete and just say hey you should
join you all in challenge like James
Harden might see that yeah you're in
control
my vote doesn't count I don't have
anything everybody can make anything
happen
yeah this is an incredible it's called
the Internet I accountability is the
greatest drug in the world absolutely
and that's I'm hoping that that will
reign true and when I finish this book
and I know hopefully another couple
weeks I'll have it done and I can start
editing and get it done I will answer me
when you're the best the best way to
sell a book and be successful that is to
give away free content about the subject
matter every day 24 hours a day so it
and it's funny I'm glad you brought that
up because one of the things I did is I
think oh I don't know maybe six months
ago you started talking about tick-tock
and at the time I took exactly the the
attitude that you said we all would
which was all right that's for you know
teenagers I'm you know I'm 48 this I'm
not gonna get on tick-tock there's no
way so but then I remember at one point
it was probably around Christmas time
you would said hey just get on it and
watch it spend a couple weeks a month
two months whatever and just watch and
just keep scrolling and just butt in it
so I did that and I was like holy crap
you know aside from all the dance you
know videos or whatever there's there
are a ton of people especially older
people my favorite is all the parents in
their 40s that are on it specifically to
ruin it for their kids I'm not a percent
100 percent so yeah and I think probably
last week I just started you know I'd go
out for a run and I'd get done and I'd
have a thought my head about something I
just put the camera on and just roll
with it and then throw it up on
tick-tock and just just to do it and
you know I was very hesitant at first
because it's a self-esteem thing you
know I'm putting myself out there the
exposures what scares the crap out of me
and I'm sure everyone else so but I just
did it and I started doing it and I
think that this is an excellent platform
where I can you know 60 seconds you know
don't have to worry about I mean I have
Final Cut Pro and I added stuff I'm like
I don't even need to do that just throw
it on there forget about everything else
make it I'm proud of you Jimmy I like
where you're headed
keep going hey so please the last thing
was regarding my question was on adspend
so I my first book came out I did a
bunch of ads on Facebook Twitter
Instagram and I'm trying to figure out
LinkedIn and get that right what I
noticed though and after talking to my
publisher is that there's a 90 day lag
between the purchase and sales data
coming out like so somebody bought the
book today it'd be three months before I
know that sale occurred the Amazon rank
moves by the second your publishers
within old school you can see the Amazon
rank change by the second no I didn't
know I don't make a note of that yeah if
you look at your Amazon rank on your
book rankings you can get an indicator
it updates every hour on how your ad
spends doing okay that's your answer I
didn't know that that'll be good to know
I did notice that when it first got put
on Amazon in January there was they had
one copy in stock which the publisher
told me that's that's how it's gonna be
until it starts to sell now I think
they're up to 11 or 12 in stock which
that's something so it's better than
zero absolutely run the ads run content
towards it link all your social media
accounts to the Amazon URL all your
default links and all your profiles okay
make make 10 15 piece of content a day
and look at the Amazon rank every hour
there's your tactic I Love You Man I
love you back see ya you you know it's
funny a couple things there to recap
that call 1 as you saw in the last 18
seconds of that call
I can go tactics all day long I spent
99% of my time
macro because fixing the sink is not
interesting if you don't have the well
fixed right you can Google what I just
said to him that's like how do you see
if your am add Spanish doing well on
Amazon it's the same thing with the
people that are mad at me in the
comments right now for interrupting it's
it's my style like I I get what he's
saying and I'm trying to move to the
point and I'm trying to bring value to
everybody I understand what he's saying
the reason all the callers are so happy
is they know that I understand what
they're saying I understand it might not
be the best style it might not be the
you know the kindest or it might come
off like I'm a douche or only want to
hear myself speak I understand
everything you're saying I promise you
100% of the [ __ ] energy focus is on
value we have an hour trying to get
through and get as much as possible the
caller might not be upset you might have
not processed it but I have you're also
more than welcome to do your own show
plus there's unlimited content of
podcasters and interviewers who let
people finish their entire thoughts you
can watch that unlimited there
everyone's got their own style and the
value comes if you really look second
later let's keep it going
you can see Gary how are you I'm nervous
I'm happy to be with you and and I'm
thanking you so much for doing this I I
just appreciate it so much just saw your
videos like three years ago and just
watching almost every day so thank you
you're welcome
so just to kind of start off I'm from
Portland Oregon
near Chris actually only but our from
Kim oh and I'm 21 basically I work out a
job that is okay but I don't want to do
it forever so recently I decided to
launch a well working on launching a
meal prep business and I love like Latin
culture it's me really fired up always
like trying to learn Spanish like been
trying to learn for a while my boyfriend
who's Mexican well Mexican American but
something I really enjoy so we decided
to start a Mexican inspired meal prep
company okay now so the meals are
healthy
so it's kind of like geared towards
people that have trouble losing weight
because they don't want to eat dry
chicken breast and broccoli so basically
I'm having trouble with social media
because one I'm not a trainer and two
I'm not a nutritionist so I need to know
like how do I provide value without
stepping out of my lane opinions and
infer and information that you know you
know people you know when I got huge in
the wine world everyone's like oh are
you a sommelier I'm like no I worked in
a wine store and you know didn't have to
work in a restaurant and get a sommelier
certificate I learned in the streets you
know just because you're not at rate
don't put trainers and nutritions on a
pedestal yes those professions
certifications can give them potential
surface level clout to be able to talk
about it the reason you can talk about
is because you're Mackenzie and you're a
human and you have an opinion on what
[ __ ] corn and salsa and and [ __ ]
meat and chicken and [ __ ] it you have an
opinion that's why don't underestimate
your opinion you don't need to be an
expert okay I promise you right now I
don't have a psychology degree I'm
willing to go up against people that
have them because I have natural talent
I didn't go to business school to you
you understand yeah you know you're at a
young age where the structure puts
certificates and and process on a
pedestal people put process or checking
the box on a pedestal versus real life
you have passion for Latin culture
that's already given you permission
right you genuinely like it yeah okay
I'm having trouble wrapping up in
trouble on social media because you have
the insecurity of not thinking you're
the part which then stops you from
making not to not to give the second
part so like let's put a nail in this
coffin like yes you have permission I'm
giving it to you here's your certificate
it's a [ __ ] guarantee certificate you
can [ __ ] ace your [ __ ] opinions
about Latin food
okay so that was kind of like yeah
obviously I have an insecurity but that
was the excuse on what to make and then
should I just like I don't even know
like just posting like cuz I don't wanna
be like there's like a lot of like
companies in my area and all they do is
they just post post like or to put your
orders and put your orders in they're
not really like providing value so
should I just like kind of like post
like I don't know have you ever have you
ever read Jab Jab Jab right hook
no okay give Dustin with it okay give
Dustin your address you know once you
come up here he'll grab you will get
your address and I'm gonna send you a
copy okay thank you
it's a but just to help everybody who's
not gonna get a copy give value give
value give out value ask for business
Jab Jab Jab right hook you know you know
talk about you talk about you and your
boyfriend talk about your favorite
things show a nice picture make a funny
video and then ask but I'm telling you
right now tick-tock I'm telling you
right now tick-tock okay thank you
you're welcome Mackenzie take care yep
it's an interesting show the lack of
beard is giving me some interesting
energy here Dustin I'm feeling kind of
like sharp what are you laughing about
just a lack of beard okay good
keep it moving tanner what's good can't
hear you all right tanner mm-hmm can't
hear you it's good turn you good yep and
go to next one thank you it's done
what's good Ryan Harmon what's good
freestyles Nick Waller what's good
good morning Derek Brad Jennifer Dalton
appreciate you this morning John
Hollywood hi holy [ __ ] can you hear me
I can't what's your name
yeah I do a shameless plug first sure so
if I could could I have a follow back on
Instagram mm-hmm it's that I have like a
stage name type thing it's Atleti lo
tosh le TT IE hello to me Oh J I know
that sounds like a porn star name but
it's like a mixture of my parents name
self and I'm doing this right now for
coloured thank you oh my god my life
just was made I'm doing this thing that
I wanted to ask you to donate to and
kind of put it out there to the fans
that are your fans I don't know why I'm
not talking like a human being so I'm
gonna go out in the community and help
the homeless like the female population
with items for like their menstrual
cycles so me and my mom like lived in my
car last year and I've been homeless at
other points in my early life and it
[ __ ] sucked to be on your period
and not having the clothes and not have
a shower and it's embarrassing and
humiliating when you you know like mess
up your clothes so I was like well that
felt like [ __ ] so I'm gonna you know
like I put some money aside cuz right
now I have my stimulus check and that's
really like all me and my mom half but I
was like well I want to give back to the
people that donate so I decided that I'm
gonna give them a ten dollar gift card
to whatever their store or restaurant of
choices as like an incentive to donate
but I'm taking tampons preferably
variety packs so it can help people with
different like needs and situations and
then pads cleansing wipes or baby wipes
and then um like over-the-counter pain
medicine so like my dollar Tylenol and
you can just DM me for that if you want
and I'll give you the address to send -
yeah I mean I'm not sending you a DM
right now with my actually can you the
impact I'll just email it to you oh I
see me up a bunch on DM thank you yeah I
just I just DM do you my email i I've
got several I'm an early investor in in
a tampon company direct-to-consumer and
I'm gonna hit them oh I want to see
where they're out I might be able to
help you so send me an email okay I
don't know how many turned all
giftcards I can afford not many and so
I'd like you to keep it and actually use
it as a base for you to get you know
tough to be selfless without first being
selfish I'd rather use use that stimulus
check to actually Chris the base of a
stability situation for you and and I
will come in and help you with what
you're trying to do from a good place
because I can and so we'll do that and
said you keep your check and start
figuring out how to build a world that
doesn't put you back into a car I'll
come in and help you and we'll get some
pads and tampons to the people that need
it that's so sick dude thank you and I'm
sorry I look like an entire whole
grown-ass man right now a woman with a
very nice heart does the Trop her
Instagram I have a funny feeling that we
can get a lot of people to help out here
it's le t TI e ello t oj l ET TI e hello
c oj slower faster bro l come on [ __ ]
you le TT IE l OT oj here you're just l
e I pay donation let's step up hit up
this lovely lady DM er and I wanted to
think I'm sorry to cut you off I just
wanted to thank you for like recognizing
my question cuz I tried as you can see
Indian like several times so the fact
that you have millions of options and
you picked me it's like huge I've been
watching it for six years and I've
wanted this from like day one so well
we're here this is safe as [ __ ] agreed
I'll be in touch yes I mean email right
now alright can I put up when I ask my
question yes of course I apologize good
know everybody I was like oh my god so I
make content basically documenting my
daily life with I've struggled with
depression since I was 16 and that's the
main reason I started the channel so I
basically was like well there have been
times where I wanted to you know harm
myself or like had really dark thoughts
and just the thought of somebody else
primarily kids I was hearing a lot about
people that were like 15 16
struggling with this when they should be
worried about you know getting their
braces off and passing driver's ed
they're like do I want to be here and
I'm like that's [ __ ] up so I was like
well you know it felt like [ __ ] so I'm
gonna it was really nerve-wracking to be
that transparent you know because
there's such a stigma surrounding mental
health but I just documented like if I
had an episode
I took my meds on camera cuz I was like
I didn't turn into a [ __ ] dragon like
there's so much stigma around even
medication and I documented like I had a
run with you know addiction and stuff
like that first up for the month of
April I document my my experiences with
sexual assault basically my question is
like I'm worried that you know because I
want to do this for a living and that
means that I have to have at least a
certain amount of income and I'm nervous
that when people have influence see my
page they're gonna see me as a liability
because sometimes I think I'm being too
transparent you know you're going you're
going to general like you know that
makes sense to me you're right yeah I've
said 80% will in the 20 and the 20
percent that you need to be connected
with anyway
won't see people always don't act
themselves because they're worried about
some other force college a boss a
professional industry accepting them
what they don't realize is they are
there then that means they want to be
accepted by an establishment by being
them fake selves mmm-hmm riot do you
know how many people literally the
entire speaking industry in 2009 like
every speaking agent every you know
agency every conference literally
communicated to me via email phone call
face to face you are you have so much
talent to be a great speaker you will
never be a big speaker because you curse
too much don't curse and you can be a
great speaker yeah I heard those look
look at these people look at these
people look at these people look at
these people you know what's happened
over the last ten years between me and
those 10 people I [ __ ] lapped them I
[ __ ] lapped them further yeah you know
why because I didn't waver I didn't want
to be accepted by an establishment that
I didn't respect anyway why the [ __ ] we
want to pander
to people that you don't respect anyway
oh my god and like the the other thing
that I realized is I was off for five
months they got me for five months
because my family was like you know law
enforcement looks at that potential
employers and I wasn't I was you know
consequently having a hard time finding
me judge the judges that pay attention
to who's giving you that advice yeah you
seen 89 fives and I want to be a public
speaker you know like Coco he didn't
want check stats like if you don't want
their numbers or their lifestyle then no
the only the only thing that you need to
layer with that is figuring it is
figuring out what you need to do
mentally and operationally and and see
and practically not putting yourself
back in a vulnerable spot of like being
in a car right like for example you're a
sweetheart
but I can't take I can't have you taking
your stimulus check and spending it on
giving when you don't have money but no
I'm saying I can sue / ha ribeaux with
money
yeah like go back to what I said earlier
like you could share the all in
challenge and keep the money and like
and start building to stability yeah the
reason I wanted to do that was because
like one of my tactics for helping to
combat my depression is like getting the
focus off of myself and I own all about
it but I wanted to do something tangible
I respect that but you need to figure
out a different relationship that
doesn't require the fact that it puts
you in a vulnerable spot because once
you go back to that vulnerable spot
you're back to [ __ ] you know what
happens yeah right pressure you know you
know exactly tell you you know exactly
what's gonna [ __ ] happen when you go
back into a [ __ ] car in October
you're [ __ ] off your [ __ ] you it's
that hard to do [ __ ] if your legs aren't
underneath you mm-hmm you're not helping
anybody what I need you to get practical
about that pressure
I will definitely one last thing I'm
sorry I'm not trying to be selfish this
is just like I don't know if I'll get
this chance again but I don't mean to
put you on the spot but like I was
really wanting to ask for a job um
because like the stimulus money is what
all we have right now and my mom bent
over backwards my entire childhood she
was single mom like oh right if you can
if you can make
content then I can give you a shot if
you can't I don't want to [ __ ] you
I'm like glad process of letting Jobs go
and I don't want to sit here and
[ __ ] you but if you are able to
design or video edit you know then you
can absolutely take that email and give
me and show me what you can do and then
I can put you in touch with my team yeah
and after kovat man I'll do it for free
like I'll walk to New York and sleep in
a [ __ ] tree what yeah except 70s will
talk okay for sure thank you so much
you're welcome you're welcome right
let's keep it going
tanner
[ __ ] and this was meant to be such a
good talk you got the epic rug behind
you I got the [ __ ] classic curtains
this was gonna be [ __ ] dynamite can
you hear me
sorry dust let's keep it moving all
right let's see who else crystal thank
you so much for being in here tad
Bernard what's good Jenni are love you
back Caroline what's good Pat Gary can
you hear me I can I can hear you and I
can see an incredible nerd Center behind
you I'm [ __ ] impressed it is it's a
passion project of mine and I love you
kicked my ass and started like I'm
starting a YouTube channel on superhero
so I'm tick-tock bro tick-tock
dude I uploaded my first tick-tock and
get like 600,000 views it's on it's
insane ya know and I kept up I kept
uploading ya know and I'm sorry I'm
trying to get through your day in and
check but here's a quick question on
that like does it have to be superhero
related or can I get my okay yeah you
know people ask me question you know how
I always say watch what I do not what I
say sometimes it's business sometimes
it's garage sales sometimes it's a jets
photo sometimes it's a throwback to when
I was a kid my report card a keynote sir
some kid in the [ __ ] Street a cartoon
like the interest yes yeah of course yes
I know it is and it's a weird I like
thought about so many questions that ask
and I'm like oh well he answered that
already oh well he answered that already
it's it's awesome thank you first of all
becomes this is what this is all about
the question becomes you all know that
I've been so consistent I've been so
historically correct like this is this
is take me I'm taking myself out of
question I've been right so long about
things that are proven in history like
at this point you know the tactics are
right the reason you're not doing it is
this which is why I've switched four
years ago I started talking more about
this you know I used to be tactics but
then when people weren't doing it when
they know the [ __ ] answer I'm like
wait a minute
all right self-confidence self-doubt
parenting like that's what evolved me
cuz I don't understand why you [ __ ]
aren't me how the [ __ ] are you watching
this right now and not posting three
times a day on tick-tock and you know
what's crazy ten thousand people ninety
nine percent or not Pat yeah nine
percent dude you your I love it man
you're so fired up and you make me fired
up and I'm sure the rest of my town is
sick of hearing me talk about Jersey
right yeah so I'm that's like ultimately
my goal and even before I start
listening to you that was it like I
wanted to be in the Gary Vee of Peoria
where I'm from Puri Illinois and some 27
I used my skills as a videographer to
build the company and I'm a freelance
I've been doing it for about nine years
and so I guess my question would be like
do I you know I know that's gonna make
me a great money I love doing it's a
great career and now I want to dabble in
some other things cuz my entrepreneurial
spirit right and do I grind at the video
for like three more years before
dabbling well I know I can dabble but
like she I double down before I invest
in other stuff for instance right now
with folks there's always yes you can
double down on video and dabble yeah
yeah Pat I want to know your 24 hours
and I want to know your seven days a
week I want I want it I want to
literally sit on your shoulder and bro
you just watched an hour and a half of
[ __ ] random videos ooh double down
sometime but what do you I was listen I
was watching four hours of Netflix a day
like kind of [ __ ] so I was like Beauty I
had time so like okay I guess some cuz I
really want to gain value from this and
I know everyone watching that's why you
do this so like right now with Sameer
went on yes
a lot of people ask me to do sweat
equity and I'm cool with that if I can
get a percentage of the business right
like have you dealt with that a lot like
is that course how do I go huh how do I
know yes you say you say yes or no okay
yes yesterday who offered me a big these
are now big companies whose yeah our
cash flows [ __ ] up we want Boehner to
do this work but we'll share the profits
on the back end and I said no that's how
I dealt with it gotcha somebody else
came in said hey we know this is
normally three million would you do it
for one nine I was like there's
something there I'm like yes yeah sure
so should there always be something a
little upfront before I like put in all
my like I do unlimited stuff for free
yeah and I pat this is free
yeah I know dude this is so sick man
I've been doing this in my town like you
know I just like get people that I see
that have the drive and I FaceTime them
and just start kicking their ass but
with these things about like documents
that I create you know send me listen to
me the answer is you're a hundred
percent in control everybody thinks for
getting gotten yeah yeah yeah that's
true you see like I'll [ __ ] this guy is
a better businessman than me he's
tricking me he's taking advantage of me
during this downtime no he's not he's
negotiating when you say no and walk
away he then finds another video person
who if he desperately wants you you're
in control
this is a perfect end to the start yeah
you're how do you handle it you're in
control
mm-hmm it's called negotiating it's
called business okay everybody's trying
to like people like so many people are
not cut out for business or having
calibrated business yet Gary they're
[ __ ] trying to get me no they're not
you don't have to say yes okay yeah but
really bad it's like so [ __ ] right
like like like you're not getting hosed
you're making a decision yeah yeah and I
feel it's not superhero [ __ ] they're not
like some evil villain that transformed
your brain and you're like yes Megatron
sorry you know like you [ __ ] it you're a
[ __ ] control that's so true man it's
don't you the problem is a lot of
whose time and efforts are not that
valuable want it to be they're actually
the wrong party they're using ego they
want the other person to succumb to them
when that other problem people are Gary
you need to I'm like I don't need to do
[ __ ] I forty thousand videographers
lined up in my [ __ ] VM right now
willing to work for free for four years
so that they can be like Babb and
indie-rock
look what's happened to Dustin Dustin
literally literally yeah riding BMX diet
bikes and all of a sudden can [ __ ]
produce any [ __ ] podcast or video
show in the world
Nessa yeah for sure I know what my value
is and and and other people do as well
maybe that maybe that you know many
people passed on three work because they
know their worth yet that was the video
that was gonna change their entire
career [ __ ] audacity when nobody gives
a [ __ ] about you is insane to me
Peter [ __ ] walking around like their
Pablo Picasso and [ __ ] Steven
Spielberg when there's [ __ ] 80,000 of
them all you [ __ ] grew up with
[ __ ] Final Cut and [ __ ] iMovie and
YouTube you're [ __ ] commoditized yeah
yeah take Gary I'm gonna watch this a
thousand times and just like relive it
but the one thing I will say like when
I'm showing people your stuff I always
start with the hot ones episode because
that was the first thing I saw and it's
like break it down first time you see it
and you're like can go through the whole
thing you're like who's this guy like
couch like you don't know this guy like
we feel like this is your life right you
know and I'm like no I've never heard of
this guy so it was a perfect mixture of
comedy right and not so like cuz I have
some friends they're like oh I don't
listen to Gary he told some high
schooler to drop out I'm like you saw
one clip from out of context you know
what I mean so like I will go like I'm
sure that hot ones probably like 10
times showing my parents showed it you
know cuz my parents are hustlers like
I'm like mom you're 65 like she's
killing garage sales her whole life they
started card shows when they're younger
like it's just this is insane man
brother I really appreciate having you
on thank you
such you have such a good spirit like I
want to be your friends like I get BMS
it's Pat Clark like I think you're
literally gonna get like hey let's be
friends
did that be awesome man yeah on the
final point all the [ __ ] in your
background like bro you need to lean
into putting out content around
superheroes on tik-tok at scale yeah
telling you I'm telling you yeah that's
right you do what Todd's place I dress
up and do unboxings I got talk shows I
get it I know that whole scene bro I'm
telling you if you go hard at tick-tock
hard three posts a day just feeling your
kindness like youthful energy like I'm
telling you you're gonna find yourself a
comic-con in a way that you could have
never dreamed and you're gonna DME and
be like Gary Vee you're I love you first
and now I [ __ ] it I really [ __ ]
love you I can't wait for that moment
man hey quick you know I don't read
books but I am jabbing her here left and
right right so I want to be a public
speaker and stuff anyway
like no with events and stuff being
canceled for a while
do you see like online speaking becoming
a big thing and like I would love a pop
apply for bigger speakers or something
like that
Boehner speakers you have no shot I'll
tell you why cuz cuz Stephen and Zach
who make the decisions they're
impossible like I'm like recommending
like people that have huge speaking
careers like the Baader speakers but but
no but you should do what I did you
should speak for free for a long time
until you don't yeah and you know I was
going to schools and volunteering but
not documenting any of it
so like I'm gonna dude like literally
changed my world so I appreciate it
let's get someone else on here I have a
good one man she sing that Josh great
show today I I I'm glad it's free to man
I really hope everybody enjoyed this
show like like somebody said comment no
beard no [ __ ] today was a very
focused [ __ ] show like we got a lot
in there Dustin in a sour like yeah got
a good amount in there what was your
takeaways anything
I wrote notes because things always are
flying all over the place for me I
always liked those parts where it's in
between the calls like when you're
talking about the whole interrupting and
giving like you wanted to give value to
people what's what's your take on the
interrupting thing right because you
know and you see like specially because
we've been doing like coffee and
commerce and we've been doing tea with
Gary Vee like people really really get
mad at me and I really understand cuz I
think they're right I get it on the
other side of it yeah I can see I can
see the perception of it and the feeling
but like but it makes so much sense to
me like point taken let's get more value
out of it I understand on the other end
there's a whole audience that didn't get
the point so that's why they want it
didn't they're not fast enough or
intuitive enough or to actually see it
so I'm [ __ ] that up and so I'm trying
to find my balance like it's a really
interesting like like look I don't think
I'm the greatest interviewer you know
I'm not [ __ ] Larry King I get that
but I but I like it's because I feel
like everybody else does the other style
and you can get that there's a trillion
[ __ ] you know videos on on YouTube
where you can get that I don't know what
do you think about it I mean I think
it's just like all ass-kissing aside
your brain is going faster than a lot of
no one else so it's like you already are
like a step ahead then like me so I like
already know what I'm going to say so I
get it like you're that's why you're
kind of getting to the point already but
it's a fine line because I also
understand the other side yeah you have
to do it for your audience and if I get
it but they don't I have to let the
right yeah it's a tricky [ __ ] game
but yeah that's very true it's why I
don't think I'll ever be the best at
interviewing but I also think like you
know like I get these email like
literally I was reading comments
somebody was mad at me yesterday for the
Shopify CEO but then also DM me like
that he follows the Shopify CEO and he
got more out of our interview thoughts
and and information from him and he has
in any of the [ __ ] hundred articles
and videos that he's watched and and
that makes me lean
into the in you know mmm interrupting I
don't even call it that it's my
interview style that is desperately
desperately trying to bring value to the
audience mm-hmm because yeah you
understand people you know what they're
they want to know and you're just kind
of like jumping to hell so I also know
what the interviewer or the person
that's asking me the question is
actually trying to get off the
interviewee and I don't want them to I
want them to get to the real thing
interesting you understand yeah knowing
that I'm told you know what up you know
I'm putting pressure on the interviewee
like you know all these incredible
guests are just like everyone's like
Gary gets all these incredible guests
and then [ __ ] doesn't let them talk
mm-hmm I don't let them to do their
press release they're everywhere else
I'm trying to [ __ ] help you and your
[ __ ] grilling me in the comments
[ __ ]
yeah thanks calm today if you don't
drink Brunello you're making a huge
mistake one of the best wines out of
Tuscany in the world today's offer is
half-price Thursday it is finally time
to step up and sign up for this if you
drink wine I can't wrap my head around I
can't wrap my head around why you
haven't signed up please sign up and
then obviously please all-in challenge
please go tweet at leave a comment in
the Instagram comments of your favorite
celebrities please please please figure
out how to get more people aware of the
all-in challenge all-in challenge calm
let's get that up let's get a new
graphic starting tomorrow Dustin because
this just says all-in challenge let's
get all on challenge comp art I see that
you do that I see what you're doing got
it you always support it with the URL
below got up yeah I'll get the others
yep yeah let's do that please support
the all-in challenge will raising I
think we're over 25 28 about 25 million
challenge we are at we are at 25 million
dollars raised in two weeks I mean a lot
to me if you supported it and if you
want to give a ten dollar donation to
the on challenge to feed the hungry
during this terrible time please check
out my auction on on challenge Gary be
calm /all and challenge here's what I'm
giving away I am giving away the
ultimate garyvee experience how should I
go okay
over the last week or so I've been a gem
with my friend Michael Rubin and helping
out on this all-in challenge that I am
accepting right now but all-in challenge
calm please go there we are challenging
some of the greatest artists
entertainers athletes in the world to
provide a ridiculous all-time experience
or one of their most iconic items in
their collection to help raise money to
help feed the hungry during this
ridiculous time and so now I have to put
up my auction
so my auction the ultimate Gary the
experience here we go I'm gonna go off
the top of the head and you can go on
all-in challenge calm to go bid on this
I am giving away okay you get to in the
course of the year you will go garage
sailing with me and film trash talk also
you can get a workout with me and Micah
Conti so I know a lot of you pay
attention to that part of my world also
we're gonna go to Wine Library and do a
twenty-five thousand dollar shopping
spree
that's right I'm gonna pay my dad well
I'm gonna donate we're gonna pay my dad
25 thousand so $25,000 shopping spree at
Wine Library I will walk through the
whole store with you tell you the war
stories and you'll buy a bunch of a wine
beer liquor whatever you want food we
are going to go to a Jets game together
you're gonna tailgate with me I never do
this when I give away Jets tickets I
never let the person sit with me so you
will sit with me during the Jets game I
won't talk to you during the game I'm
completely focused but you'll get that
so the ultimate Jets experience tailgate
full game with me as well also I'm going
to give you one week play at Vayner
media so this is for you and a plus-one
by the way so the two tickets the will
be some plus ones we'll do some just me
and you depending on what is one full
week at vaynermedia getting consulting
and business advice from team Gary B and
me for the entire week hanging out in
the pit where the shows done you're
gonna be a guest of my podcast we're
gonna do a wine dinner for you and seven
of your friends at Hunt fish club in New
York City and I'm gonna fly you all paid
plus 1 to 3 of my keynotes and we'll
work on those details the ultimate Gary
Vee experience I hope you bid on it I
hope you get involved I hope we raise a
lot of money to help people that need it
all so what's so fun about the o-line
challenge
is you get to challenge people to be in
it I am gonna challenge all the Boehner
sports athletes I expect you in there so
that is number one number two I'm gonna
go with ooh you know what
Tim Berlin the super producer who's
completely lighting up Instagram
Tim Berlin the super producer I'm
calling you out and finally I got one
the Undertaker
one of the great wrestlers of all time
please join the challenge everybody go
to all in challenge calm please support
this the experiences are gonna be nuts
we've been working bleeding out of the
eyeballs for the last week putting this
all together you're gonna be blown away
what you're about to see on social media
hashtag all and challenge please check
it out and please go to your favorite
celebrities athletes and entertainers
and leave hashtag all and challenge to
get them involved the all and challenge
please take it